It could happen at any point in time
because no matter what happens, no
matter what point in time, if you have a
a being that is more advanced come to
any society and say, "Hey, we are we
realize that there's going to be
problems in your world and we're trying
to help you." There's no one that
wouldn't want help. There's been a lot
of talk in the media and in the news
about UFOs and aliens from the Pentagon
and the military. Have they always been
here? And who are they?
Find out on this episode of LED Live.
[Music]
Light exposing darkness.
What's up everybody? Welcome back to LED
Live. Today we got a hot topic,
something that I've been passionate
about all my life. Aliens and UFOs. And
the more I looked into this subject, I
started finding out things weren't
exactly as I thought they were, believed
they were. We got a special guest. He's
actually the newest member of the LED
team. This is Brad Burnham. Our team is
growing and we're excited to have you
on, but we wanted to have you on this
particular show because you have a
passion for this subject and actually
made a really cool documentary about it.
Link is in the description. So, what
what inspired you to make that and just
tell us a little bit about it.
Man, about 10 years ago, I realized this
was going to blow up. This is going to
become a big deal, but I wasn't in a
position where I wanted to do it right
then. But when this stuff come started
come out in the news and started
becoming mainstream, I started realizing
people don't know the the truth behind
this stuff and we need to do a little
more revealing behind this. So I started
putting some stuff together and I
realized that we could really do some
some heavy damage for the enemy by
revealing this stuff. So, I put together
this uh this trailer, this YouTube
video. It's it's a documentary,
basically a 30-minute documentary that
reveals what's really going on here with
Bible scripture with Bible commentary
and with demonic worshiping defectors.
Roger Mno, in other words,
yeah.
Yeah. You're talking about 10 years ago.
There's a lot more content now than
there was 10 years ago. I mean, now
they're talking about it openly in the
media, whereas before it used to all be
swamp gas and tinfoil hat conspiracy.
But, uh yeah, dude. I I watched this and
I was really impressed. So, I want to
show the trailer right now.
But but what they're saying to us now is
it's going to affect Christian belief.
It is going to require a rereading of
the gospel as we know it. And that's the
kind of information that we are
receiving from the highest levels of
Vatican intelligencia.
If you're an alien and you want to get
baptized, the Pope is in favor of it.
Pope Francis reiterated his view Monday
that everyone has the right to be
baptized. And apparently that invite
extends even to Martians
that are coming to warn the inhabitants
of planet Earth of the impending
destruction of the planet. People are
going to eat the stuff.
There are things flying around up there
that we haven't fully identified yet.
I got it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh,
there's no sound.
It's in the woods.
Yeah,
there's footage and records of objects
in the skies that we don't know exactly
what they are. We can't explain
144 separate sightings of UFOs by the US
military
every day for at least a couple years.
What you are looking at is something
that is a demonic presence. A senior
looked at me in the eye and said, "I
want this program to stop."
A war of the world view is approaching.
The the term the occult in that whole
world is much more a part of the UFO
phenomenon.
[Music]
Great job, man. I mean, that was heavy
hitting right there because it really
dealt with with kind of hitting at the
at the at the key point, I believe, is
why we need to be looking into this
subject. Like the guy said in the very
beginning, this will rewrite the Bible
for you. It will make you need to
reinterpret religion. And anything that
does that, to me, my alarm bells go off
for sure.
It's kind of a fascinating concept, you
know? It's like, well, the pope is ready
to baptize an alien. It's like, well,
why does the alien need to be baptized?
You know, think about why why it is that
we get baptized. You know, we're
baptized into Christ. It's partaking of
his death because of our sin. So, if an
alien needs to be baptized, did they
sin? Like, do they need Christ? How do
you know they haven't met him already?
Like,
yeah,
there's a lot of questions there, right?
Theologically,
maybe the aliens will tell us that
they've met him already.
Maybe that's a
I I mean, if you just think on that
simple concept right there, what does
that mean? that in the universe there's
other things that that people sin and
that's going on in the universe. Like
it's not isolated to us down here. You
know,
there's so many questions. It just
opened up a whole new realm of things
that that could be introduced into
theology that are really dangerous.
Right. Right.
And I think it's super important, even
vital for the church to talk about this.
It, you know, this is so out there now
that if you don't address it, you're
setting people up for deception. I mean,
at this point, as weird as it sounds,
you know, you don't think about going to
church and hearing a sermon about UFOs
and aliens, at least not a couple years
ago,
right?
But now, because it's so on the
forefront, we have to address it.
So, you know, we see that this thing is
getting propagated in a realistic way.
There's a new show on Showtime called
UFO, and it's it's all about what is
what's going on? What's going on out
there? What are these UFOs? And and it's
coming at it from a real angle. This
isn't like a series like, you know, a
sitcom or something. This is like a
reality show.
Whoa.
I've never seen anything like that. What
the actual
What is it?
When I look in the sky at night
nowadays, I've got the knowledge that I
didn't have before.
I don't know what that was.
That there's something out there and
it's real.
When this whole thing started, I tried
to tell people about it.
No one believed me. But now I do have
evidence.
Someone This is going to be hard for me.
They encountered something over the sky.
Most sightings of UFOs can be explained.
Oh gosh. Only a small percentage can't
be.
Was giant, quiet, and was amazing.
Within less than a second, crosses right
in front of me. Poof. and it's gone.
[Music]
And then bam, the New York Times story.
It changed everything.
This is it. This is when the government
is going to reveal the truth.
Oh my gosh.
It was a bombshell, right? That's what
it was.
Whether you accept it or not, some
people actually saw this stuff.
People are actually going to believe us
now.
Imagine if it was acknowledged
officially.
[Music]
that UFOs exist.
Our own divisions would suddenly feel so
much smaller.
It was dark money. Even members of
Congress don't know it's there.
This is too big to turn away from.
There's something in our skies and we
don't know what it is, but there's
something coming.
The world needs to get ready for what's
about to happen.
[Music]
So yeah, I I think it's interesting that
they're talking about, you know,
preparing for something and they're
saying, you know, if if they announced
that they were here or whatever, how all
our differences would be set aside. I
mean, we're talking about uniting the
world together, right? That's prophetic.
You're talking about the one world
religion, one world order, whatever, if
you will. So I I kind of see that's
where things are going with some of
this. change everything. And the the the
strange thing about this plan, this
demonic plan, is that it could happen at
any point in time because no matter what
happens, no matter what point in time,
if you have a a being that is more
advanced come to any society and say,
"Hey, we are we realize that there's
going to be problems in your world and
we're trying to help you." There's no
one that wouldn't want help. Right.
Right. We actually found exactly that.
Mikey and I um took a camera and we went
downtown. We we in the Bible belt, so we
just wanted to see like, you know, do
other people believe in this stuff? And
we started interviewing people and it
was amazing how many people were like,
"Oh yeah, I totally believe in aliens."
And then it was like, if they had the
answer to peace, would you listen? Oh
yeah, absolutely. And it was just like
no question about can we trust them or
anything, you know?
It's really amazing because you know,
you think about what does that mean from
a biblical worldview perspective.
So you can't have peace now. doing is it
not available? Is it not attainable? And
if you think of the way most Christian
theology goes, it's kind of like, yeah,
there's there's sin and there's all
these terrible things and you know, one
day that's going to go away, but you
know, the reality is I still have a
pornography problem or I still have an
alcohol addiction or a drug addiction
and you know, the Bible's not really
been any help. So, you're open to all
kinds of answers,
all kinds of things, right? I think
prophetically we see that the world's
going to get worse and worse and worse
until Christ comes back, he's going to
bring the peace, not aliens. So if some
other being comes and says we have the
answer to peace, that's a red flag. You
know, if it's not Christ, but what if
they portray to be Christ?
Well, it's even been driven by media.
the media engine, the Hollywood engine
has been trying to force this idea that
we are going that we would like to uh
someday be talked to and be seen by an
intelligent race that would uh help us
out someday. I mean, we see it in
everything from from Disney. We see it
for everything from any Hollywood. JJ
Abrams actually made that last trailer
that we saw,
right? I mean, this is not a small
person in the middle of, you know,
Arizona. I mean, this is a major
filmmaker jumping in and pushing a a
realistic looking I mean, like
documentary. That's the power of a
documentary is people accept it. Kind of
like reality TV. Oh, wow. It must be
real cuz they're running around with
shaky cameras. And why is the footage
always shaky when you see a UFO? I mean,
can people not hold that thing still?
It's way out there, man. Zoom in on that
thing.
I don't know. But yeah, we we have
government officials, people who are
putting their job, their reputation on
the line saying this is real and now
they're it's almost like a sigh of
relief that now people will believe us,
you know. So I I think that's going to
cause a lot of people who never
considered the whole alien thing to
really start contemplating, well, what
is it?
And the only answers out there are these
things like uh History Channel, ancient
aliens and stuff, and that is going to
lead you down a whole road of deception.
I mean, I fell for that where they're
teaching you that Moses was led out of
the wilderness by a beam of light from a
UFO. They're following a UFO out of the
wilderness and stuff. I fell for that
years ago when I was I've always been
intrigued by aliens and I became a
Christian and I'm like, "So, how do
these go together?" History Channel told
me and it made sense. You know, I think
a lot of people will fall for that. You
were just talking about the Hollywood
machine. What What do you see in this
here?
Oh my goodness.
So, the Eternals is something that's
coming out. um superheroes, but it's
always interesting to me how spiritual
the superhero movies really are.
And I think people always go, "Oh, you
guys are making, you know, like
connections here that are always there."
Well, that's cuz they're always talking
about this kind of stuff.
They openly tell you that these
characters are based off of gods.
Superman is Zeus, Batman is Hades,
Aquaman is Neptune, and they kind of fit
into the the pantheon of gods of a lot
of different cultures. So yeah.
Yeah. I mean, we're not just making a
connection that's not there,
right? And and so the previous Marvel
superhero movies have been kind of
somewhat human, right? And this is
really strange because Marvel's taken
another step back into a different kind
of new superheroes
that are not displayed as people.
Basically, they're saying that these are
people from away from Earth and they are
alien. Yeah. Basically, and and they are
coming to help
Earth.
I mean, it's it's the same scenario. And
they're based off of these Samrian gods,
the same ones that have been talked
about constantly by Marvel and talked
about constantly by the UFOologists that
ancient aliens and all that. Wow. Okay,
let's look at this trailer then.
We have watched
and guided.
We have helped them progress and seen
them
accomplish wonders
throughout the years.
We have never interfered
until
now.
[Music]
So, it's interesting that they're that
they're basically making the statement
that they've always been here and that
they're here to help. They haven't
really meddled in stuff, but they're
going to come and actually be out in the
open and active involvement with
humanity. And that to me is fascinating
spiritually speaking because I believe
that we're coming into a time that the
devil is going to step out into our
view.
Interesting soundtrack. Did you hear
that? It's the end of the world. It's
like goodbye. Like they're telling you,
okay, it's the end of the world. these
eternal alien gods are have been helping
humanity all through history. Like,
dude, they're they're feeding you this
whole ancient alien thing and packaging
it up as a superhero movie,
man.
Yeah, it's it's fascinating. You know,
it's like another explanation. You have
the atheistic view that accepts
evolution. You have the biblical view
that accepts creation, you know, a young
earth creation. And now this is almost
like a third view to catch people who
were, you know, it was it was aliens
that helped us get here. That's how we
evolved or advanced, you know.
Yeah. Even like a hybrid.
Even Richard Dawkins, a militant
atheist, when he was asked, there's a
really cool documentary called
expelled. No intelligence allowed.
He said he he could accept that we were
seated here by aliens.
Oh, wow.
The God of the Old Testament is arguably
the most unpleasant character in all
fiction. jealous and proud of it. A
petty, unjust, unforgiving control
freak. A vindictive, bloodthirsty ethnic
cleanser. A misogynistic, homophobic,
racist, infanticidal, genocidal,
philicidal, pestilential,
megalomaniacal, sedom masochistic,
capriciously malevolent bully.
So that's what you think of God.
Yeah.
Well, then how did it get created?
Nobody knows how how it how it started.
It could come about in the following
way. It could be that uh at some earlier
time somewhere in the universe a
civilization
evolved by probably some kind of
Darwinian means to a very very high
level of technology and designed a form
of life that they seeded onto perhaps
this this planet.
Yeah. So an atheist could accept that.
Yeah. It's interesting. How is that all
that different really?
Where did the aliens come from? Oh, they
were seeded by another race. I'll answer
that because I think that the problem
with believing in an actual god is now
you are morally held accountable for
what the way you lived your life. I
think that's the pinnacle point that
they reject against. It's like we we'll
believe in the most crazy theories of we
came from an orb and this thing started
with nothing and grew into what it is
today and this complex thing we called
life. But we won't accept the theory
that God actually created this world
because now I have to be held
accountable.
You bring up an interesting point
though. So it's like of well are they
moral the aliens you know it's like I'm
looking at Stargate here you know and
Stargate you know the guy the premise
was you know he believed that the
Egyptian hieroglyphics this
archaeologist he believed that they were
being interpreted wrong and that they
actually pointed to an alien race and so
they you know they unlock this Stargate
they go through and then come to find
out it's the aliens who were like the
pharaohs that were acting like the gods
of Egypt and were, you know, kind of
dominating humanity,
placing these people on different
planets, seeding the planet with all
these different races. It's the same
story that's been told by the Ancient
Aliens agenda, the movie. What is it
called? It's a series, right?
It's a series. Yeah. On History Channel.
It's been out for like 12 years now.
But like you're saying, the pharaohs and
stuff, they were looked at as gods. Like
gods. And biblically, I mean, am I crazy
to think that those could have been like
um manifested demons? I mean, is that
far-fetched that these things are like
demons in the physical form?
I think throughout humanity's history,
the demonic world has interacted with
them. I mean, you clearly see that in
in, you know, uh
Egypt, they turn the snakes into into
rods into snakes. I mean, what else can
do that besides
a spiritual entity, right?
Right. Exactly. Yeah.
Or at least it looks like they did.
Yeah. You know, probably like devil's
slight of hand.
Yeah. Yeah. You know, at some point
they're able to to make a visual, you
know, representation of something that's
like not there because I mean, we see
that with with different celebrities
today saying, "Oh, yeah, we just, you
know, saw aliens pop in, you know."
Oh, yeah.
So, yeah, clearly this has been an
agenda or or something that has been in
the media for a long time since the dawn
of television. We're talking about
Forbidden Planet was a black and white
movie and you had Star Trek, Star Wars,
and it's just on and on and on. It's
always these uh beings that live on
another planet has been seated in our
mind. Um but we have another clip here
from a guy who was in the occult, right?
Oh man. So this is this is huge. So um
in Montreal, Canada, there was a guy
named Roger Marno. And Roger Marno was a
uh he was being groomed to be a part of
this demonic worshshiping church. And
they had actually sought him out and he
wanted to and they wanted to bring him
in because they saw him as a great asset
to their cause. And the the problem was
though, not the problem, the good thing
was that God was working in his life
just as Satan was trying to get him to.
And so he had placed him beside a
Christian fellow at work that that when
when Morno heard about specific uh
Christianity, he said, "Well, I want to
know more about that. I want I want to
hear both sides of this story." And so
he went to his Christian guy who turns
out to be an Adventist. And he said,
"Why don't you why don't you give me
Bible studies?" And he was there every
night learning about this. And because
of that, uh he became a Christian. And
through this Christianity, he tells a
story about what he learned inside that
church. And this is one of the things
that he learned.
Roger, when I was a teenager back in the
1970s, I remember a song that came out
talking about the age of Aquarius.
And since then, we've seen the
development of the new age and I
wondered if back when you were involved
in spirit worship if they talked about
new age at all.
Oh yes. It was a big thing that was
coming up. one of the uh major
deceptions of the last days
and the priest told us uh he had we
talked quite a while and then he said
could I have a bit more of your time I
want to tell you something very
fascinating he says the grain plane the
master's grain plane for harvesting the
nations for for harvesting the
multitudes of the earth into his calls
just before the close of the great
controversy between the forces of good
and evil so we continued, you know,
after we express ourselves that we're
deeply interested to know more about the
activities of the spirits. And he said
it's going to be done in a unique
manner.
This this grand plane says is going to
take people people are going to eat the
stuff because he says spirits, demon
spirits will
declare themselves to be inhabitants of
far distant planets in the galaxies
that are coming to warn the inhabitants
of planet earth of the impending
destruction of the planet unless
something seriously
proper is done. So, I think it's worthy
of noting that this interview is done in
the 80s,
but he's reflecting back on when he was
part of that occult. And I think that
was even way prior to that, like 40
years prior to that.
So, we're talking like, you know, to to
hear something that was mentioned nearly
60 years ago
that we're going to deal with this alien
thing and then now it's like coming out
in our day and age, I think is a very
fascinating point. And he said that it
was a plan that was going to happen in
in the last days. It's like the final
deception when there's a lot of
problems in the world. I mean, we're
talking we live in a society where
everybody has to wear a mask and get an
injection and there's pandemics and
there's climate change and we got to do
something because the world's going to
burn up.
I mean, these are big problems that
affect the whole world, not just,
you know, a state or one nation, right?
So, this is a perfect prime time for
this kind of deception to roll out. He
mentioned uh influential people that
would start channeling aliens and stuff.
And we're seeing that kind of stuff. Uh
Demi Lovado did a show with Kesha, who
Demi Lovado is a self-professed
Christian now. A year later, she's
telling Kesha on a Zoom on a Zoom
meeting for the whole world to see that
you can actually channel aliens and
meditate and they'll come to you. and uh
and she convinced Kesha that this was a
good thing. So, you're talking about two
influential people that have all this
platform for these young kids. Oh,
meditating and channeling aliens is
something cool and we should do that.
The night that I asked that orb to come
back and hang out with me in my dreams,
I I fully astral projected that night in
my sleep and I I wouldn't Yeah. I just I
had this experience where like all of a
sudden I was like Sounds so wild.
No, I know. I don't know if I want to
say this.
I'm so here for it.
Yeah. Well, it just was like I had this
experience where I I was like, "Come
back. Let's hang out in my dreams and
then I was in my room that night and
these beings, which I don't remember
what they looked like, they were just
like, "Do you want to come back to our
planet?" And I'm like, "Hell yeah." So,
I like am sucked out of my room and I'm
floating over the planet and I wasn't in
like a ship or anything, but I'm just
like hovering in like deep space and was
just like, "Wo." And they're like, "You
want to come see?" And I was like, "Hell
yeah." So then I fly to this pink and
purple planet that looked like Dr.
Seuss, very Dr. Seussike. And then I
woke up and that's all I remember. You
know how you know how JJ Ad Abrams
brought up the concept of or actually
that documentary from Showtime brought
up the concept that um our differences
would just melt away if we actually had
some sort of exterior threat.
Yeah.
Um you know it's interesting because the
whole world is being pushed in a certain
direction and they're uniting in a war
so to say.
Yeah. Very prophetic.
Yeah. Everybody's starting to have the
same problems, you know, when natural
disasters start to affect
it's a worldwide problem.
Everybody, you know, or pandemics or
whatever, it's it's a worldwide problem
and people are looking for answers, you
know, the whole climate change. People
are like, we need we need answers.
Affects everybody here. Like what are we
going to do,
you know?
And yeah, he was saying that these
demons would manifest as
uh
problem solvers basically.
Yeah. Beings from far distant galaxies
that'll say something proper has to be
done to fix your world. They're coming
as saviors,
false messiahs.
And wouldn't it be interesting if
everyone came together because of that?
All humanity.
That reminds me,
it kind of reminds me of that Reagan
speech, right?
Don't you have that?
Yeah.
But I've often wondered, what if all of
us in the world discovered that we were
threatened
by an outer a power from outer space
from another planet?
Wouldn't we all of a sudden find that we
didn't have any differences between us
at all? We were all human beings,
citizens of the world, and wouldn't we
come together to fight that particular
threat?
I want to point something out here that
to me is fascinating biblically because
what he's actually saying is so contrary
to the biblical worldview of the end of
the world, right? I mean, didn't Jesus
talk about there's going to be two
groups of people? There's going to be uh
wheat and tears, right? And there's
going to be those bundles that are
bundled together that are for
destruction. And then there will be a
bundle of of people that will all of a
sudden um enter into um eternal life.
Right? But notice how he's phrasing that
something's coming. There's a threat and
if it came together, all of our
differences would go away. Meaning there
isn't a a group that's set for eternal
life and there isn't a group that's set
for eternal damnation. It's literally
like, "No, we're we're all in this
together to fight against that thing
that's coming."
It's kind of fascinating because you see
this presented from two different
angles, right? You see the you see the
alien type like, "Well, we need help
from all these outside visitors and we
want to contact them and they're our
friends." And then you hear the other
narrative that's like, "These are our
enemies. We have to fight against them.
We have to protect ourselves. They might
be trying to destroy us."
Which brings up a lot of interesting
ideas. Like one, we would be capable of
destroying them. You know, we're smart
enough to do that. you know, all these
all these kind of questions arise.
Well, maybe we need help from the good
aliens to fight the bad aliens.
I mean, that's another that's another
angle to to come from like there that
there's good and bad ones and they're
both vying for our help or dominion.
Yeah. Cuz when you look at these movies,
you got like ET, the friendly alien, and
then you got the one like Independence
Day. You know, I think there's a reason
that you do see both sides. But what
he's saying, like what you just said,
this is contradictory to what prophecy
tells us. Revelation 16:13-14
says, "I saw three unclean spirits like
frogs come out of the mouth of the
dragon, out of the mouth of the beast,
and out of the mouth of the false
prophet. For they are the spirits of
devils working miracles which go forth
into the kings of the earth. These
devils are going to actually go to the
kings of the earth and the whole world
to gather them to the battle of the
great day of God Almighty."
So, we're not unifying together. It's
not like we're all getting together for
this good cause and we're going to fight
this evil alien threat. It says that
demons are going to gather the world
together to fight Christ when he
returns.
And that's what the Bible says.
And how did the demons trick Eve in the
beginning? Right?
Through a deception, through appearance
of something else, a snake, right?
That's what the Bible says.
And so what do you think is going to
happen in the end? They're gonna do the
exact same thing through a deception as
appearing as something else.
They know it works.
Yeah. Yeah. I see.
So, this is this is really ramping up. I
mean I mean you know maybe there were
some isolated experiences that were
happening over the years. Um people saw
things but it was seemed to be more
infrequent. Now it's like they're
starting to actually see this on a
regular basis.
Yeah. I actually saw a news clip that
said since co there's been double the
amount of sightings. Meanwhile, UFO
sightings in New York have nearly
doubled since the pandemic began.
Double the sightings since co I think
it's ironic that CO happened 2020 right
after December 2019 when Trump opened up
the space force. Now we have a new
branch in the military. We're not just,
you know, fighting here on Earth and
we're we're fighting something a space
threat,
you know, whether that's asteroid or
aliens or whatever. They're not really,
it's kind of ambiguous, but they're
still they have an army that's looking
towards space to fight to defend Earth
against something from out there.
The government is seeing these more and
more often. What's it what's fascinating
about this though is that these things
are primarily appearing over nuclear
subs and and the most the latest
technology. So that the government can't
talk about it because their most
secretive classified information. They
have meetings about this and they're
saying, "Well, we saw that thing again,
but we can't talk about it. So, don't
talk about it. Don't say anything about
it. We're skeptics." And so, because of
that, it's become a very secretive thing
that the government doesn't want to talk
about because if they reveal that, they
have to reveal what they've seen and
what were you doing out there in the
ocean with all that stuff that you've
had.
It's kind of like a national security
threat or something,
right? And so, this stuff is kind of
coming out now since this stuff has been
on the news, which we kind of have a
clip about.
All right, let's check that out.
So, you're seeing it both with the radar
and with the infrared, and that tells
you that there is something out there.
Pretty hard to spoof that.
These photographs were taken in 2019 in
the same area. The Pentagon confirms
these are images of objects it can't
identify. Lieutenant Graves told us
pilots training off the Atlantic coast
see things like that all the time.
Every day. Every day for at least a
couple years.
Wait a minute. Every day for a couple of
years.
Yeah. I don't see an exhaust plume.
Including this one off the coast of
Jacksonville, Florida in 2015. Captured
on a targeting camera by members of
Graves Squadron.
Look at that thing. It's rotating.
My gosh.
They're all going against the wind. The
wind's 120 knots west,
dude.
Wow, man. This is it's a really surreal
moment because for since 2012 is when I
really started seeing things a different
way when it came to the alien thing. And
I kind of had my own speculation that
this is how it was going to happen, you
know, and to see it like this where now
we're really talking about this. It's
really like a topic where the news is
saying there's something that we can't
explain. It's pretty surreal to be in
that moment.
And these are legitimate pilots. These
are these are guys who in order to
become a fighter jet fight pilot, you
have to have less or better than 2020
vision. You can't have glasses. You got
to be able to spot things and know when
they're going to appear because things
are coming right at you right past. And
when they say they see something up
there and one of the clips they say,
"Hey, uh, pilot, did you?" And the guy
said, "Did you see that, too?" as they
they mesh together when they're talking,
both of them are seeing it. Uh, they
have multiple systems seeing it.
Something's there. and uh and they're
very concerned.
Yeah. They're sitting there analyzing it
saying, "I don't see exhaust or
whatever." Like, you know, this another
situation where they're putting their
job and reputation on the line. If you
can't identify this thing and it's
something that exists, then you're fired
basically.
I don't know if it's still this way, but
it used to be like you couldn't even
have LASIC surgery.
Yeah.
To correct your vision to become a pilot
like that in the military. like you had
to be born with and keep that, you know,
better than perfect vision
in order to do something like that.
That might have changed, but you know
what's frustrating is like this stuff is
always the worst footage known to man.
It's the most pixelated grainy. I'm
like, isn't this the military? Don't
they have like
Yeah, whip out your iPhone and
billions of billion dollar equipment.
Like, how is this so bad?
Well, so we've been looking at the
physical stuff. Clearly, this is
something that you can pick up on radar.
High officials are are seeing it. But I
I saw a clip from uh a documentary in
the 80s about about Satanism and stuff.
And there was this artist guy. He was
actually an art teacher. He was done
with God. Cussed out God. Said he wanted
to worship Satan and see what Satan had
to offer him. And so he made a deal with
Satan. And and he said that his faith
was kind of getting weak. And so he
asked Satan,
"Reveal yourself to me. I want to paint
you so I know what I'm worshiping.
And I just want you to see like the
painting that he painted. This is very
interesting.
One time when I was very weak in my
faith with Satan. I said, "Prove that
you exist and you're real in my life."
That night I got home from school, I
closed the door. I went out in the
garage and I grabbed a canvas, stuck it
out my easel. I grabbed my paints and I
just I had a definite purpose in every
move that I made. And I knew the whole
time I was doing it that another force
was physically directing my body.
something from the unknown world, the
non-visual world was going to become
visual so that it could have more power
over my life and could encourage me more
and I could worship that thing more and
I could have more of a a realistic image
that I could look at. And I painted for
several hours and I was finished. It was
the most fantastic painting I'd ever
done.
Avatar.
Seriously, the most fascinating painting
he ever drawn. Most fantastic painting
he ever drew.
Third eye.
I mean, look at this. This is identical
to Avatar, man. We can't even like and
look I mean even to to the point of what
this thing is wearing the the flat nose
the the eyes are yellow and the blue
skin like I think it's interesting that
this guy wanted to know what he was
worshiping and this is what Satan or the
demon or whatever portrayed themsel as
and then James Cameron is creating this.
You know I believe that we're
everybody's inspired by something.
You're either inspired by God or you're
inspired by the enemy. This was some
concept art for the original Avatar. And
you can see this one looks a little more
like this because it doesn't have the
ears. But I found a clip of James
Cameron on Oprah and he's talking about
where he got his inspiration from for
these movies.
Oh yeah.
And I want you to hear how this concept
of the Avatar came to be. So this is
going back to 1976.
I think the thing that's interesting
about it is that
I've already got a a tall hot blue girl
in that movie. Her name wasn't Natia and
it was in a completely different
context, but I was already thinking
about it then. A lot of stuff comes to
me in dreams and I remember it.
Sometimes I write it down. Sometimes
it's an image and I'll go I'll go draw
or paint that image. And I quickly
painted as many of them as I could
remember. One of them was a glowing
forest with a river of light running
through it and trees that kind of looked
like fiber optics.
Well, guess what? Cut to, you know, 30
years later, I'm making a movie where
we're spending millions of dollars to
actually create that image. But that
image came in a in a dream when I was uh
18 years old.
Now, this is interesting. This is one of
the first pieces of artwork that I did
for Terminator, even before I wrote it.
Uh, and it's the uh the chrome skeleton
coming out of the fire. That was kind of
a defining image. That's the image that
came to me in a dream in 1981.
I always think of the the universe as
like a a giant bank vault lock, you
know, and the tumblers are constantly
moving and every once in a while the
tumblers line up and you got to listen
for the click. So, I mean, people ask us
all the time like, "Do you guys just
think everybody's conspiring against
Christianity?" And you're talking about
different people, different parts of the
world, different organizations,
different companies, but I think they're
getting influenced. We We have testimony
after testimony of actors saying, "I I'm
I got multiple demons in me. You know,
that wasn't me when I acted that part. I
I went to my trailer, just kind of
lifted my hands, and something came into
me." M
so the scripts and the actors are
admitting that they're having
interaction with the spirit world and
you know we could test these by the
Bible. Is this a dream from God? You
know God gives dreams and visions. Well,
you look at the movie Terminator. We did
a video on it. Check out the Terminator
um video. But those movies have these
biblical titles. Ter Terminator Judgment
Day, Terminator Salvation, Terminator
Genesis. And yet it's a complete
reversal of the Bible. Mhm.
You would think, oh yeah, it's it's John
Connor JC. He's the savior of the world.
He's going to save the world from being
in, you know, taken over by Terminators.
But if you really look at the whole
saga, you see that the Terminator is the
bad guy or the Satan character who in
part two becomes the good guy, saying,
"Come with me if you want to live." And
by Terminator Genesis, John Connor is no
longer the savior. He's the enemy. So
they they team up with Terminator,
destroy John Connor. It's a complete
reversal of the Bible. And then when you
look at Avatar, they live in a place
called Pandora. And when you look at
what Pandora's box is, it was a a god
created the first woman. First woman,
think of that, Eve. And he gave her a
gift of this forbidden box that she
wasn't supposed to open up. And the
moment he left, she opens this forbidden
box. And that's why we have all these
terrible things in our world because
this first woman opened up this
forbidden thing
Pandora's box.
Yeah. So they live in Pandora and
there's this giant tree that is called
the tree of souls and it taps into your
neurology somehow and it's a it's a tree
of knowledge. So and that's portrayed in
a good light. So this is not a vision
from God. This is definitely a Gnostic
gospel
and we and we know the Bible says that
even Satan can transform himself into a
being of light. So these these things
these angels
not blue aliens, but we're it's really
interesting that these things are are
portraying them as different different
things around to deceive us. In fact, I
think you have some other uh artwork.
Oh, yes. About really fascinating. If we
could take a moment to like unpack this
a little bit just from the Bible
because
he's being inspired by a dream. And if
you look at accounts of other things
like the Twilight series, how did the
lady get that idea? Right? It was like a
dream or a vision.
The Harry Potter series, right? Dream or
a vision.
This is interesting. If you listen to
what the Bible says in Deuteronomy 13,
if there arises among you a prophet or a
dreamer of dreams, okay, now we need to
take notice, right?
Yeah.
And he gives you a sign or a wonder and
the sign or wonder comes a pass of which
he spoke to you saying, "Let us go after
other gods,
other beings, right?"
Oh, makes me think of all the superhero
gods.
Yeah. Which you have not known, and let
us serve them. You shall not listen to
the words of that prophet or dreamer of
dreams.
For the Lord your God is testing you.
Now, why this is important, right? To
know whether you love the Lord your God
with all your heart and with all your
soul. You shall walk after the Lord your
God and fear him and keep his
commandments and obey his voice. You
shall serve him and hold fast to him.
And it goes on to say, you know that
prophet or dreamer of dreams that led
you astray, you are to put them to
death.
Right now, there's a really fascinating
biblical connection to other parts of
the scriptures here. And um
in Joel chapter 2, right, God's spirit
is poured out upon his people. And do
you remember what it says in there?
We're going to read It says your your
sons will dream dreams and stuff.
Yeah.
Prophesy. And
this is from Joel 2:28. It says, "And it
shall come to pass afterward that I will
pour out my spirit on all flesh. Your
sons and your daughters shall prophesy.
Your old men shall dream dreams. Your
young men shall see visions. And also on
my men's servants and my maid servants.
I will pour out my spirit in those
days." He says, "And I will show wonders
in the heavens and the earth, blood and
fire and pillars of smoke."
Wow.
So here the spirit is being bestowed
upon God's people, right? And then
they're having visions and dreams. Well,
what is the distinction between these
two groups, right? Well, in Acts 5:32,
it says that the Holy Spirit is given to
those who obey.
Now, here's a really fascinating link.
Think of all the people we just
mentioned, right? Your sons, your
daughters, old men, young men, men's
servants, maid servants, right? If you
go to Exodus 20 and you start reading a
Sabbath commandment,
it says this, remember the Sabbath day
to keep it holy. Six days you shall
labor and do all your work, but the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
your God. So, this is part of God's law,
ten commandments, okay? In it, you shall
do no work. Who? you, nor your son, nor
your daughter, nor your male servant,
nor your female servant, nor your
cattle, nor your stranger who is within
your gates. For in six days the Lord
made the heavens, the earth, the sea,
and all that is in them, and rested the
seventh day. Therefore, the Lord blessed
the se the Sabbath day. Hallelujah.
That first one you read about um
is in Deuteronomy 13.
If it's true, don't believe it. If
even if it comes true, even if it
happens,
yeah,
even it's a miracle. You're like, I
can't deny this. I seen it. It happened
with my eyes.
I I have no explanation for this.
That's not it. That's not the test to
see if it came from God. But the test
really is following God's commandments.
follow
because he says in Isaiah 5:20, he says,
"To the law and to the testimony, but
speaks not according to this word,
there's no light in it." But if you back
up to verse 19, he starts talking about
um witches and necromancers and seances
and stuff like that. And it's like, you
know, aren't we supposed to listen to
the word of the Lord instead of another
word, another voice, another influence?
Yeah.
Right. So you're listening to those
mediums
comes down to God's word in the end.
That's the safeguard. That's the thing
that is everything is tested by.
And that's what Revelation talks about
that he's going the dragon is going to
make war against those who keep the
commandments. So that's a test, right?
Well, you know, our channel is not uh
shy to to take a look at pop culture and
see the messages that are being pushed
out into the world. And there is a new
film coming out called The Tomorrow War.
Mhm.
I wonder where he got that script from.
Maybe that was a dream.
You know what I mean? I think it's very
fascinating that they're discussing
there's a war going on in the galaxy and
that there are these beings that are
from some distant planet and they're
going to come and destroy our world. And
the one thing that they all have in
common is once a week, one day out of
the week, they take a Sabbath rest.
And that's the enemy.
It's the enemy that is keeping God's
commandments after.
Isn't that crazy?
That's something. And and I mean just
the title alone, tomorrow war, it's like
tomorrow is like a prophecy or a
revelation or something. The future war.
I mean this is we're talking about like
a prophetic war.
That movie was released on a Friday.
What's tomorrow?
Wow. Tomorrow war.
It's the Sabbath.
War on the Sabbath.
So it's kind of an interesting little
thing. I know some some guy put a video
out on this. I watched it. Yeah.
Um had a lot of good stuff. I think for
God's people to take away is, you know,
you don't take the elements of the movie
too far
because the enemy,
that's not where we get prophecy,
right? You know, we get prophecy from
God's word. And whatever God reveals in
his word, that's safe,
but we can't take things like, you know,
the tomorrow war said, you know, it's
2022 that everything goes down. Well,
you know what? God didn't reveal that in
his words. We can't take that too far.
Maybe something will happen, maybe it
won't. But you don't want to get too
wrapped up in like the enemy's details
because that could very well lead us
astray.
So we have to get our information, you
know, from the Bible. This is the safe
information. Anything else is kind of,
you know,
has to speak according to this word.
Yeah. That's why you got to know what
the Bible says.
Exactly.
You know, I mean, you're not going to
you're not going to spot this deception.
It's going to come at you like a freight
train. And if you have no bearing
whatsoever, then you have no barometer
to say, "Hey, that's not what the Bible
says or whatever." So, you got to really
spend time reading the Bible first and
foremost, not just paying attention to
the deceptions.
Yeah. I feel horrified thinking about
people who just have not been raised up
on Christianity in any way whatsoever.
And this alien thing comes and all. I
mean, they have no barometer. They're
just this is truth. This is reality.
You you mentioned that there's another
person. So, it wasn't just James Cameron
that had or uh yeah, James Cameron got
this blue alien being from a dream. This
other guy, the Satan worshipper, uh had
his body possessed and painted this
thing. But Alistister Crowley, the
self-proclaimed most wickedest man in
the world, influenced people like Jay-Z
and the Beatles and Led Zeppelin. He had
he wrote a book called Magic spelled
with a K and The Lima. And in these
books he would talk about this being a
demon. He said it was a demon. He didn't
say it was visited visitor from another
planet. He said that he was visited by a
demon and that this being's name was
lamb lam which I think is interesting
because Jesus is the lamb the true lamb
and the name in Tibetan means way or
path and Jesus said I am the way. So
this is clearly well he said it was a
demon. It's a demon who is deceiving
coming as a impersonation of Christ. And
I mean, this is like a no-brainer,
right? I mean, it looks just like a
alien gray that people draw.
I think it's interesting that they are
are a bit ugly.
Yeah.
Like, I don't know. I just imagine, you
know, God God there's beauty in God's
creation and it's like, why are these
things always these like slimy creepy
like, you know, just
that's what the Bible said. The Bible
says they're they're beautiful beings.
Angels are beautiful beings and so
they're portraying themselves as
something that
are ugly and terrible and and perhaps
kind of throw you off.
Throw you off.
Yeah. More deception.
Um so we we were talking about this guy
um what's his name again?
Tom Dong.
Oh man. Tom Dong. He, this is an
interesting guy because he was an
original um artist, a music artist in uh
the
Blink 182, Angels and Airways.
Angels and Airways. Yeah. And he had
always been interested in this alien
phenomenon. And he actually quit blink
182. And he uh decided he wanted to go
and pursue this further. And so he got
into the highest ranks of the military
through his through his the US military
through his um uh
charm.
Charm. Yeah. And and his influence. So
what what has happened is he said, "You
know what? I have experience
in leading and giving a message to young
people
through my music.
Let me guide the message that you're
trying to get across to the rest of the
world through documentaries, through
books, and and everything else because
he wrote children's books, right?
He wrote ch So so so I'm getting there.
So this is this is fascinating." And
this is all in the documentary that I I
created. So I go into more detail in
that but they basically what he did was
he he created the he he told the
military he said I understand you are
having a an a UFO problem and I want to
try to reveal this to the rest of the
group without making anyone scared about
it. And so I think I can do that the way
I've been doing that in my messages in
my songs by slowly revealing it to the
young people of our nation. And so he he
wrote uh books uh and he wrote and he
created documentaries and he's still
doing that right now. But what's
fascinating is what he says about these
things that he is uh that he's
researching. Check it out.
There is a very very strong link between
what people think demons are from the
Bible and other religions um and the UFO
phenomenon. And what you have is
something that doesn't like man period.
That's a fascinating statement, right?
Yeah. He didn't he didn't say like these
Christians are just crazy and they're
putting something together. It's not
there. He's like there's a very very
strong link,
right? That Yeah. That wasn't even like
that's just crazy and ridiculous. It's
like no, no. If you've read what a demon
is in the Bible, this is very much like
that and this thing hates human humans.
Like that's fascinating to me.
Yeah. You you you think about it
especially like from the perspective of
maybe this modern movie like Venom,
right? Venom is an alien.
You know what Venom does? It possesses a
dude.
Mhm.
You know, and it's like angel, you know,
demons possess people. We have those
stories in the Bible. It's kind of
interesting.
Well, even the new age, they they
believe that the aliens are gods and
that they can channel them and all that
stuff. And they they call them star
people, I think. And when you look at
the definition, it says they believe a
star person, a star child is someone who
is like a a seated alien or a walk into
an existing human body.
Yeah. Like in a possession.
Yeah. I'm like, how can you believe that
some alien being from another planet
comes here and then just walks into a a
physical being just walks into another
physical body. I mean, to me, we're the
Bible talks about that and that's an
unclean spirit. That's not an alien
being. Um, we're going to put a link in
the description to this whole thing
because this was like over an hour long,
like an hour and a half interview on
Coast to Coast AM. And he said a lot of
interesting things. For one, he was
saying he had security clearance with
the CIA, and there's things that he
can't say, but he's releasing a lot of
stuff that he can say. And he says what
the CIA has told him is that they're
well aware that aliens are here. They're
well aware that there's good and evil
aliens that are battling and that the
aliens are distracting the world with
this fake idea of religion religion and
causing religious wars to keep us
distracted from the truth about the
alien battle going on. And this isn't a
conspiracy because what we what I found
in in the Wikileaks Wikileaks has uh
produced a a batch of emails from the
Podesta email link leak that what
happened was has to dong talking to high
ranking military officials about you
this UFO thing. So this this isn't not
this is official emails from the
military between military officials. You
can look them up and about this guy
talking about this. So, he's not just
sitting here making this stuff up about
what's going on. He's actually
legitimate and talking about this stuff.
You mentioned that he's written some
books and I think that one of the books
that he wrote was with a very known
occult bookwriter, right?
Yes.
As well.
So, you know, it's interesting that he's
teaming up with somebody who's clearly
part of the occult. The occult is like
one layer away from Satan, right?
Yeah. I mean, we got um the Satanist who
painted the Avatar thing. We got
Alistister Crowley who drew this demon.
So clearly when you're messing around
with the new age or the occult, you
start having interactions with these
things. I don't see I don't meet too
many Christians that are like, "Oh yeah,
I see aliens all the time."
So why didn't you go to his pastor?
I mean, you're going to go to all these
other occult people that that that think
they have an ability to communicate with
these things. Why not? He said it was
from the Bible. Why not go to the Bible
and go and seek out religious
understanding of this?
So, yeah. What What is your
watch led? We should actually send him
our show.
There we go.
That's right.
It might open his eyes in a certain way.
But he actually um said he was a
Christian at one time and he left. Yeah.
He grew up Christian and he says, "I
don't claim that religion anymore. I I"
He says, "I I basically pray to these
things." He uses Eastern meditation to
to bring these things up into the sky.
And that's the primary way that most of
these ufoolologists go about obtaining
information is by contacting them.
And it's very it's very strange.
And it's not like a walkie-talkie
either. I mean, it's prayer.
Yeah.
That should be a red flag right there.
Emptying yourself and and and basically
thinking something. I don't want to go
too far into it or even giving anybody
ideas on how to do it, but but it it's
very very very strange. And uh but but
to give him some legitimacy,
there is also um a military guy who he
combined with um that left the military.
His name is Lou Alzando. And Lou Alzando
uh was given the the uh task of looking
into all this classified UFO data. He
was a part he was a director of the
Pentagon
and um when he started looking into all
this UFO data, he said, "You know what?
this is definitely something we need to
look into a little bit further. There's
something here. And he went to his
highest advisor and said, I want to
declassify some of this stuff. I want to
talk about some of this stuff because
it's it's a big deal. And his his
adviser turned to him and said, haven't
you read the Bible?
This stuff, we know where this stuff is
from. and he says well he got he got
upset at this guy and left the military,
declassified some some uh some UFO
videos and leaked it into the media.
Watch this. Um this is a person I
respected tremendously. Very very senior
person. He told me he said Lou I want
you to stop stop doing this.
I said okay sir I I certainly can but
may ask why. And he says well we already
know what it is. Now, at that moment, I
I honestly thought maybe it was our own
technology and I was running up against
some super uber secret sap. And you
know, they were telling me to stop. And
I said, "Okay, sir. So, so it's ours."
And he said, "No, that's not what I'm
saying." And he said, uh, he asked me
point blank, "Have you read your Bible
lately?" And I wasn't quite sure where
he was going with that. And I said,
"Well, sir, I I I think I know what it
says. What where are you going with
this?" And he said, 'Well, then you
would know that these things are are
demonic and we should not be pursuing
them. Yeah. And uh I I he was he wasn't
kidding. He would that's exactly how how
he felt.
So this is a Pentagon. This is a DO
Department of Defense
official
uh saying, "Stop looking at UFOs because
they're demonic."
Correct.
Wow. That that's very telling. I mean,
somebody that's that high up, he he
didn't just say, "It's my personal
conviction. I'm a Christian and I
believe that these are demonic." He
said, "We already know what these things
are. They're demons."
That's interesting to me.
It's even a little more alarming that
this conversation is on the table in our
Pentagon and yet it's still being like
received as these are real aliens. You
know what I mean? Because clearly
they're being fed this information. So,
you know, they're they're welcoming the
deception almost at that point. Mhm.
I think it's a lot of like what he said,
you know, a lot of it's like coupled
with stuff that's classified and you
know how the government is is like we
can neither confirm nor deny.
Yeah. you know, they say that on
everything because it's like a it winds
up being a legal matter and they're
always trying to hold off the press
because they don't want to leak certain
things out to the public or other
governments or and I was I was listening
to something recently that was, you
know, it was they were saying we're
getting ready to release all this stuff
and and it's like, well, what's the
government's position or response? And
they're like, well, they probably
actually hope it is aliens because if it
was another government, that means
they're a lot more advanced than we
think they are and maybe a lot more
advanced than us. And we don't like that
idea.
Yeah. Someone at the Department of
Defense dropped the ball and they don't
know who this stuff is. That's what
they've said right now. We don't know
who this is. And we don't think it's
anybody any other countries, any
adversaries. So, we're not really sure
what's going on with this. And the
videos that you're seeing on the news
right now are the same videos that this
guy leaked out to the press in order so
that he would get the Congress involved
to get the Pentagon, his high Pentagon
officials that were denying him access
to this stuff to get them to react and
bring back a declassified report and and
just start the ball rolling and
declassifying this stuff.
All right, so the elephant in the room,
where are they going with this? Where's
this end goal? Like they're leaking
things. They're putting it out there.
They're making these connections.
They're publicly starting to to to put
that information out that yes, there are
there are demons, but where's this
going? What's the endgame?
I I don't know. I honestly think that
these leaks are purposeful. They're
trying to get the public interested
because, you know, if we just got
invaded 10 years ago, an invasion
happened, everybody would go into chaos.
I mean, you saw the world war of the
world's radio show. People killed
themselves over a radio program that was
having commercial breaks and saying,
"Hey, this is a, you know, fictional
thing." Yeah. And people were like,
literally people kill themselves and
things. So, in order to prevent panic
and chaos, they're letting little things
leak out here and there on purpose to
make the public say, "Hey, what is this?
We want to know that truth. Give us the
truth." And, "No, it's weather balloons
and all this. No, tell us the truth."
the demand from the public now that you
know I think that that's what they want.
They want the public to demand answers.
They're priming them to to be
inquisitive and then they're going to
hand them the solution which I believe
is honestly Satan masquerading as Jesus.
They're preparing for something huge and
out in the open and I believe that's
where all this is going.
Brad, I know this is it. This is a lot
of stuff that's in your documentary. So
tell us again where where can we get a
hold of this documentary? How can we
watch it? Yeah, there's so much more I
want to say on this. There's so much to
say about it. Uh, and and we're only
breaking the surface of what's in the
documentary. Go to starfallov.com
and you can watch the whole thing. It's
out now as of today as we release
release this video, I believe, on a
Friday. And you can uh you can watch the
whole thing.
That's probably just part one, huh?
Man, this could be a whole series.
Yeah.
So, I just want to
go through a recap real quick. We know
that these things have been seen
throughout history. So, it can't all be
military, you know, technology or
something. But some of it has been
military technology. The US government,
the Nazis, they created flying saucers.
But these things defy physics, man. They
go, they're clocked at over 1,000 miles
an hour. Don't break the sound barrier.
They make 90° turns at that speed. And
the driver doesn't get thrown to the
wall. They split off into two. They
materialize, dematerialize. So they defy
physics. Um we didn't mention it but the
Catholics they at Fatima they saw this
glowing orb that anyone today would say
was a flying saucer but they thought it
was Mary. So a connection with the
spiritual world there.
They have their own telescope to view
these things too in the US. The Vatican
has a telescope in the US to to watch at
their uh on top of some mountain
somewhere that is
the Lucifer one largest observatory
called the Lucifer. Wow. Uh so the new
age people they channel them they
contact them they meditate and see these
things as like um ascended masters. The
occult sees them Alistister Crowley and
all these people and their message man
I've seen testimony after testimony of
abductees whether they whether they're
releasing it through hypnosis or
whatever. They're they're being able to
tell you what was told to them. And the
aliens have a message for humanity.
Your problems of the world are based on
religion and Jesus isn't who you think
he is. He's an ascended master and every
you are all gods who can reach Christ
consciousness. This is a a totally
different this is an antichrist message.
And u I believe that these are deceiving
spirits in the last days which 1 Timothy
4:1 and2 says now the spirit
expresslessly says that in the latter
times some will depart from the faith.
These are Christians because they have
to be in the faith to depart from the
faith. Right? Departing from the faith,
giving heed to deceiving spirits and
doctrines of demons, speaking lies and
hypocrisies, having their own conscience
seared with a hot iron. And we do not
wrestle against flesh and blood, but
against principalities and the rulers of
darkness of the which of the rulers and
darkness of this age, against spiritual
hosts of wickedness in heavenly places.
That's where people are seeing these
things. These are false Christ, false
prophets that will rise and show signs
and wonders that would deceive, if
possible, even the very elect. But take
heed. I have told you all things
beforehand. So that's what this whole
message was about that we don't want to
be deceived in the latter times when
these demons that are flying around in
the heavenly places are giving a false
prophecy giving false gospel that is
going to deceive if it were possible
even the very elect. How do you be part
of that elect? You have to study the
word of God. You have to know the the
truth in order to identify the
counterfeit or else you're going to be
deceived by this thing. If you or
someone you know is interested in this,
please share this video with them. If
they're going down the road I was in
where I was a Christian believing in
this ancient aliens concept, please
share this with them just so they can uh
you know have some evidence to weigh out
so they don't be deceived by this thing
when it comes when whatever comes, you
know. Don't forget to like, share, and
subscribe and check out starfallmov.com
and we will see you all next week.
[Music]
I am the god of the new world.
I love anime.
I love it. I mean, I can't watch enough
of it. The duelist, who they say can
speak with the spirits.
The sins will destroy the commandments
forever. A suspicious list of names
prompts an investigation at a local
school and concern from parents.
The death note is derived from a
Japanese animated show.
The girl told authorities she got the
idea from a Cartoon Network show.
Mom, it's Mr. Satan. I recognize that
voice anywhere.
Say, say
somebody
[Music]
Oh,
hey.
[Music]